election day in Georgia is tomorrow you
know about this for a U.S Senate runoff
with major major implications for this
country now the polls show Republican
Herschel Walker and Democratic senator
Rafael Warnock locked in a tight race
still more than 1.8 million people have
already cast their ballots Friday was
the biggest early voting day in
Georgia's history Nicole killing is
Atlanta with more on the story Nicole
good morning we're all watching this one
yeah a lot of folks are Gail and you
know look both of these candidates have
very packed schedules today CBS News has
learned that Herschel Walker is expected
to hold a teller rally with former
president Donald Trump while Senator
Warnock is kicking off his day here with
union workers and deploying surrogates
across the state
are you ready to win this election
incumbent Democratic senator Rafia
Warnock ended Sunday just as he began it
in church you're gonna vote for somebody
whose last name begins with a w
just make sure
and the Baptist Minister who pastors
this same church Reverend Martin Luther
King Jr did got some backup from the
choir
[Music]
in a virtual phone bank with Stevie
Wonder
[Music]
wanna
it goes around Georgia needs Herschel
Walker instead of star power it was
Senate power with South Carolina's Tim
Scott and Louisiana's John Kennedy
stumping for Republican Challenger
Herschel Walker do y'all know Raphael
Warner has spent over a hundred million
dollars against me already
and we're in a tot with the end zone in
sight the former Georgia football star
also spent part of his weekend
tailgating with supporters at the SEC
Championship Game
it's all part of an intense ground game
to drive turnout on both sides this
election is so critical even though
control of the U.S Senate is no longer
on the line voters say Georgia still
matters if two or three of them do not
lockstep with the Biden agenda then we
have another potential Republican
senator that might break that Trend we
have an opportunity here to create a
real majority a real 5149 situation so
this is hugely important
more than a quarter of active voters in
the state have already cast their ballot
so the focus is really on driving
turnout election day but there's real
concern since the forecast is calling
for heavy rain today and tomorrow in
fact we're already getting some rain now
so both campaigns are urging voters not
to let the weather deter them Tony
Nicole thank you very much